[MUSIC PLAYING]
With a billion new users
expected online by 2017,
there's a huge opportunity
to grow your business.
Most of these users will
be in emerging markets,
so you should consider
how they may differ
from your current audience.
Here are 10 tips to
help you get ready.
Speak your user's language, in
your app and on the Play Store.
Make sure your users
understand your content
by localizing your app.
First, dates and time should be
internationalized and displayed
according to their
phone settings.
For many markets, numeracy
is higher than literacy.
Use fewer words and
provide graphical cues
with audio and voice support.
Keep interaction simple.
Avoid scrolling menus and use
tappable, browsable interfaces.
For example, Auto
Complete and curated lists
can be better than
searching and filtering.
Design your app for
different languages,
allowing for different sentence
lengths and structures.
The app translation service,
available from the Developer
Console, can help.
And remember to test everything
with native speakers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Deliver the right
content and features.
Research new markets
thoroughly and build features
on local trends and preferences.
For instance,
think mobile first.
Don't rely on familiarity
with email and web passwords.
Offer phone number-based
registration.
Multi-SIM phones
are also popular,
which you can detect
since Android 5.1,
in order to, for example, adapt
your apps data usage by SIM.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Allow for slow and
intermittent data connections.
Many users will not have access
to reliable data connections.
It's important to adapt
your app to use less data
and, if possible, to
also work offline.
Try to separate UI from
network activities,
so users can precache
content over Wi-Fi.
Optimize all images and
consider using webP.
It's smaller in file size than
alternatives for the same image
quality.
You can also give
users control over
when and what connection
they use, particularly
for large downloads or syncing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Accommodate low end devices
and smaller screens.
In emerging markets,
many devices
tend to have small
screens, so make
sure you optimize your UI by
testing on multiple screen
sizes.
You should also adapt your
app to low end devices, which
may have low memory,
low processing
power, and low resolution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ensure your apps will run on
older versions of Android.
To reach the next billion
users in emerging markets,
consider backward
compatibility to Jelly Bean,
and where practical, back
to Ice Cream Sandwich.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Optimize for less phone memory
and shorter battery life.
Your user's phone may
have 512 megabytes
of internal memory
or less, so apps
need to be efficient
with memory usage.
Also disk space is lower
than developed markets,
so keep your APK size
under 10 megabytes.
Optimize the
contents of your APK
by using highly targeted images,
mobile optimized libraries,
remove redundant content,
and enable ProGuard to
out unused code.
Also, make sure your app can
run from SD card storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Consume only the
data you need to.
In most emerging markets,
users will pay for data
as they use it.
Your app's initial
download, each update,
and foreground and
background data all add cost.
Balance the benefits of
an update with the cost
to your user of installing it.
Consider less frequent
releases and balance
the cost of installing an update
with the benefits to your user.
Avoid background
services where possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Reflect local buying
habits and cycles.
Localize your prices and
remember a simple exchange rate
conversion may not be right.
A good onboarding flow is
vital to ensure maximum buyer
conversion, provide app
and subscription trials,
so the user can try
before they buy.
And when planning promotions,
understand local buying cycles.
Link promotional activity
with holidays, events,
and monthly data
plan refresh dates.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Grow your audience
with app promotion.
When you're ready to
launch, app install
ads can help you
grow an audience,
and universal app campaigns
that you set up straight
from the Developer
Console make it easy.
Your campaign is
automatically optimized
to meet your CPA targets by
finding the right balance
on Google Search, Google
Play, Google Display
Network, and YouTube.
Research the best local
marketing channels
you can promote your app
on and leverage YouTube
and other popular social media
sites in target countries.
Also try App
Invites, a smart way
to grow your audience by
letting existing users invite
their Google Contacts
via email and SMS.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Engage and support
your users locally.
Don't leave your users to work
things out for themselves.
Start by reading and
responding to app reviews.
Then go local by
creating user groups
for countries or languages
through social media channels.
Build a core of power
users and encourage them
with involvement in beta
tests and update plans.
And look for ways to help
them share their findings
by offering them access to your
support team or developers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For more information on
building your app for success
in emerging markets,
read our checklist
in the Distribute section of
the Android Developer website.
If you want more tips on how to
grow your app or gain business,
check out the other
videos in this series
and download "The Secrets to
App Success on Google Play.